[Music]
welcome back to CBS this morning it is
now time to bring you some of the
stories at our top of the table this
morning this is where we each pick a
story we'd like to share with all of you
at home at your table and with each
other at our table that's right who's
going first
Michelle I'm going first this is serious
business folks
Evelyn Yang the wife of Democratic
presidential candidate Andrew yang
revealed for the first time that she was
sexually assaulted by her gynecologist
when she was pregnant with her first
child back in 2012 in an interview with
CNN yang said she kept the assault a
secret and did not even tell her husband
about it in that interview she described
what happened I was confused and then I
realized what was happening and then I
just kind of froze like a deer in
headlights just frozen I knew it was
happening I remember trying to fix my
eyes on a spot on the wall and just
trying to avoid seeing his face as he
was as he was assaulting me
was just waiting for it to be over yang
finally told her husband many months
after their son was born she said she
decided to go public now after being
moved by stories from voters she met on
the campaign trail yang wants to use her
platform to help other women
Evelynn Yang and 31 other women are now
suing Robert Hadden the man who
allegedly assaulted her along with
Columbia University and its affiliates
in 2016 hadn't pled guilty to two
charges against him and lost his medical
license he was required to register as a
sex offender he did not go to jail
however and he denies all allegations
except to the ones he pled guilty to
Andrew yang released this statement
quote I'm extraordinarily proud of
Evelyn for telling her story and my
heart breaks every time I think of which
she had to experience those are tough
allegations I mean he's 31 32 women and
all yes yeah yeah and you see this every
day